hello there friends so I've now been
back from Northwest flow festival for
two weeks and I wanted to put some
thoughts in order and share them with
you all both about how it was uh kind of
going to that event as well as why it
was so different for me Drex here from
Drex Factor POI sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain and
did my first fire Festival in like four
years it's kind of a trip I want to talk
about why but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
becklinen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so as I'm recording this I have a
student who's been taking Skype lessons
from me now for several months
who is in town and wanted to meet me
face to face so I'm on my way down to
the National Mall to meet up with her
um but I thought it was a good
opportunity to do a walk and talk about
some other stuff that's been going on so
roughly two weeks ago uh something
happened that has not happened in many
years namely I went to a fire festival
or I guess I guess I should more
accurately call it a flow Festival that
is Northwest flow Fest based in Seattle
Washington
it had been
nearly 10 years
since I had been in the Pacific
Northwest and it had been 15 years since
I had been in Seattle itself and of
course it had been four years since I
had attended a live flow event now I
definitely walked into Northwest flow
Fest totally intending to take a lot of
footage to do like you know a full recap
video show everybody all the fun stuff
that was going on there and in the end I
think I wound up with a total of like
three clips of video which was not going
to make for a very good recap
unfortunately but I think it is good to
talk about why that was the case and uh
why I'm not upset about that so I had
something of a goal walking into
Northwest flow Fest
most of the time when I go to a fire or
flow Fest I come out of the weekend
feeling absolutely spent and exhausted I
go back to wherever I came from and
really struggle to kind of integrate
myself back into life
and I wanted to come out of the weekend
with as much if not more energy than I
had when I went into it and critical to
that was listening to myself to my body
to my brain when it was setting off
warning bells that I was a little
overwhelmed that I needed to take a
break that I needed to rest that I
needed some space or to set boundaries
so a big problem for me in years past
doing flow festivals is that I haven't
been terribly good with any piece of
that there is an enormous amount of
pressure especially when you're a super
well-known teacher to be available at
all times to be fully engaged at all
times to be doing all the things to say
nothing of the fact that when you go to
a flow Festival part of the reason
you're going there is to connect with
other people so it becomes really
tempting to just throw yourself in the
deep end
and tire yourself out in the process so
real quickly I did just want to
highlight some things that I really
liked about Northwest flow Fest because
after all that is usually the point of a
recap video for one thing I really
really love their business model of
sticking flow festivals in major cities
and public parks it makes us more
visible it makes it more likely that
random people are going to discover us
be curious about what we do and try and
you know sign up to be a part of this I
saw a lot of curious people come through
the park that day and I think I helped
talk at least one of them into taking
classes in addition I think they had a
pretty good teaching lineup you know
Seattle definitely has kind of an
embarrassment of riches when it comes to
awesome flow artists in the area more so
than I realized there were a bunch of
people that I saw over the course of the
weekend that I was just kind of like
whoa wait a second I didn't know that
you lived up here they also had really
good signage and by and large the site
was pretty easy to navigate
um the one kind of downside was that
there were a lot of spaces where we were
kind of struggling to find shade on what
turned out to be a very very hot day but
overall like the the setup there was
fantastic and it also has to be said as
somebody who has put down a flag in the
sand many many times around teacher pay
not only did they pay me but they paid
me more than I asked for that is the
only time that has ever happened in all
of my years going to the fire and flow
festivals and it was really appreciated
not the least of which because they were
absolutely right that I should have been
asking for more in the first place and
that kind of brings us back to why I
don't have more footage of the event
because you see I had to teach two
classes in the course of one day and
also perform in their teacher showcase
at the end of the evening
I had maybe a couple hours off in
between each of these individual things
and more often than not what I found I
needed to do in between was to go
stretch out to give my mind a chance to
relax for a few minutes and quite
frankly to work on some other projects
as much as I was really Keen to be
running around and capturing footage of
everything I kind of realized that the
way that I could give the best
experience to my students as well as the
people in the audience was to make sure
that I was fresh mentally and that meant
that going and capturing footage kind of
got knocked off of the list of things I
had to get done so there was definitely
something that dawned on me the morning
that the event started that I think I
had kind of maybe had a little bit of
awareness of but I'd never really been
able to put into words see as people
showed up that morning they were so
unbelievably Overjoyed to see each other
whether they already knew each other or
not they would throw each other into
each other's arms they would spend all
of their time excitedly saying hello and
you know kind of having to come back to
attract themselves of what their
original task was just because
everything was so exciting and bubbly
now as I've been doing therapy the past
few years I have become more and more
aware of the fact that I sometimes
engage in a thing called dysregulation
that is putting myself in a position
where I am abundantly excited or nervous
or anxious and that this is a state that
felt so normal to me growing up that
it's something that I sometimes actively
seek out now as an adult I can create a
situation for myself where I'm
experiencing peace but I will still feel
this drive to try and break up that
peace not because necessarily I want to
be in a space where I'm all kinds of
anxious and uncomfortable but because
that's what feels normal and when I'm in
a space where I'm relaxed and at peace
it feels very unfamiliar sometimes the
body craves the thing that is familiar
with even if it's unpleasant like many
flow artists I am neurodivergent and I
have quite a history of traumas in my
past and I think that to a certain
extent part of what happens in the flow
Festival world and you know in the flow
World in general is we are creating kind
of like a little container in which we
can experience dysregulation in a way
that feels relatively safe I mean for
God's sakes we spin fire around our
bodies we deliberately induce an
adrenaline kind of peaked state in
ourselves and as I recognize this
phenomenon happening it also dawned on
me that I could make a different choice
and so I did in moments when I felt
myself getting excessively anxious I
would give myself space to go calm down
in moments when I felt myself driven to
try and over socialize myself I gave my
myself permission to take a break from
people so in the days after I noticed
something that I had never noticed
before
namely myself engaging in people
pleasing that's the thing that I know
that I do but I had never caught myself
really engaging in it before this
so I made a choice at that point
I knew that if I stayed hanging out with
people I would probably continue to
engage in this so I decided that I
needed to chill I communicated to people
that I needed to go home I made a choice
to not go to certain social functions
that I was invited to I made a choice to
restrict the amount of social contact
that I had out there maybe someday I'll
be at a place where when I'm in a social
situation I can turn off that need to
engage in people pleasing but as it
stands right now it's harder for me to
do when I'm around people so I just
decided that it was time to chill and
give myself some space
and that felt really good not the least
of which because that was an option that
until then I didn't even know that I
really had and it felt really good to
exercise that and also be able to
exercise some agency in that moment all
right so I am now at the Metro stop so
I'm going to go ahead and mask up and
get on the train cool so I am off the
metro and just wanted to wrap up my
thoughts here
um so overall I made my goal I came back
to DC no more exhausted than when I left
and in the process I
did a lot of practice in setting
boundaries saying no to things and
listening to both my body and my brain
which is pretty lovely
um
I didn't know a lot of these things were
options when I first started doing fire
and flow fests and you know it's good to
know that they are I'll be going to my
next event here in a couple weeks Great
Lakes flow a link to them down in the
description but I'm feeling a lot better
about that I was a little anxious coming
into this year as to what it would be
like to go to these events because
historically I just come out of them
feeling so spent and exhausted but I'm
feeling a lot better about it now
I like knowing that these are options
and hopefully you all like knowing that
these are options too I hope that those
of you out there that likewise struggle
with trying to you know cheap your wits
about you at the festivals look at this
and recognize that you have some options
to work with too and exercise those
options if you do leave me a comment let
me know how this worked out for you and
if if you have your own tips for setting
boundaries at flow festivals let me know
down in the comments as well did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like share comment and subscribe
to help other people find it and help my
channel grow this video would not be
possible without the kind support of all
these lovely people right here these are
my flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people will sit down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous supports and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
so by heading on over to patreon.com Rex
factorpoi and signing up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out some of my other videos on Flow Arts
culture and specifically the fire
festivals I will go ahead and leave a
link to a playlist of said videos down
in the description as well as up here on
screen if you're watching on YouTube
also the YouTube brilliant thinks that
you might like this top video here
because a lot of other viewers of my
channel have so maybe give that a look
as well
thanks so much for watching make sure to
have a good day get out and flow and
I'll see you next time oh and thank you
once again to Northwest flow festival
for having me out peace